nous attendions bonjour bienvenue sur
antenne 2 voici les deux candidats qui
vont passer cette demi heure avec nous
valérie et james valérie bonjour bonjour
je m'appelle va ériger 60 ans où je sais
je les fais pas j'en ai 18 18
j'habite à rouen et je fais des études
de mathématiques en quelle année de vous
en première année 4 et 3 vite sans
réfléchir
4 et 3 attendu 43 43 james e bonjour je
m'appelle crâne ce j'habite en est on et
je suis photographe photographe donc
orléans face à rouen le premier des
trois rendez vous voici les 9 15
c'est à vous valérie de commencer avec
québec anicien voulez vous jouez vous
allez disposer d'un petit ronde pour
tracer une ligne
j'aurais joué avec jean marc thibault
jean marc thibault bonjour jean marc
thibault bonjour j'ai 18 ans oui
l'angleterre sa marque en novembre 1940
âge oui l'angleterre en novembre 1982
découvre avec surprise que le maniaque
sexuel geoffrey prime qui défraie la
chronique et le bananière bernard menez
en extrapolant si ce maniaque qui
défraie la chronique est vraiment un
très très mauvais anglais pourquoi jean
marc top chrono 30 secondes à très
mauvais anglais est à négocier ou c'est
un étranger peut être un espion
étrangers 1
un espion étrangers
un belge un espion tout court
1 d'accord oui très bonne réponse de
jean marc thibault cet employé du
contre-espionnage travailler pour les
allemands
depuis 14 ans c'est une histoire de
moeurs qui a démasqué cet anglais
amateurs de jeunes femmes même vous
allez monsieur foucault qu'il montrait
son micro film sous le manteau dans
l'académie des 9 james et à vous de
jouer
eh bien nous allons reprendre sim sim
bonjour monsieur simon bonjour messieurs
dames en 1917 ville madame poincaré
femme du président de la république est
l'objet d'un enlèvement manqué la presse
sera muselé et n'en parlera pas à cause
de la personnalité de l'agresseur qui
sera également muselés par la suite
pourquoi si les bains je vais vous dire
je le sais car ce cetc c'est mon grand
père qui a enlevé madame poincaré pas
bon non non non mais je vais vous dire
mon grand-père était je vous fais je
peux vous faire abymes
oui je suis un ami vous allez comprendre
pourquoi mon grand père était employé
dans un zoo et il était orangs outans
oui et c'est un orang outan qui y en a
qui a enlevé madame poincaré excellente
réponse de cible il s'agissait en effet
d'un orang outan échappé d'un cirque
voisin de l'elysée il sauta sur la
présidente poincaré l'a pris par la
taille et tenta de l'emporter dans les
arbres je veux trouver à la point car la
branche en branche
merci sim une croix devant sim valérie
c'est à vous je le vois jouer avec
bernard menez bernard menez en 1947
madame poinsot chapuis obtint une
distinction qu'aucune femme n'a vécu
jusqu alors en france qu'elle ait ce
poste de haute responsabilité bernard
elle a une grande responsabilité et une
grande responsabilité
donc ces politiques oui oui mais c'est
tout lui mais
politique grand bon ben je sais pas moi
elle était absente et
ministre les choses comme ça mais alors
ministre
alors qu'est ce qui fit d'originalité
ministre donc la femme ministre femme
elle suit la première femme
alors oui oui oui la première bien sûr
oui bien sûr en dc bonne réponse bernard
à la santé publique dans le gouvernement
schumann c'était en 1947 très bonne
réponse de bernard menez 22 de plus pour
valérie et un petit rond devant vous
bernard que faites-vous james et bien
marcel maréchal
marcel maréchal que je vais aller
rejoindre dans quelques instants
marcel maréchal lyonnais exilés à
marseille vivante actuellement à paris
voilà vous savez tout de lui la question
le 26 mars marcel le 14 septembre et le
29 septembre 1908 eu lieu en france un
phénomène atmosphérique lumineux
pourtant considérée comme rare chez nous
quel est ce phénomène top chrono 30
secondes
nuit blanche non non marcel amont fond
voilà phénomènes atmosphériques l'asu
n'a quoi une éclipse des éclairs au
chocolat va sous silence ou la soucoupe
une soucoupe volante non un
extraterrestre souffler monsieur
castelli la soucoupe volante
non c'est pas ça du tout une connerie
une aurore boréale
du 3 au 5 mai 1908 certains journaux
allèrent jusqu'à prévoir la fin du monde
et d'autre et vire une une punition du
ciel en verre l'anticléricalisme
heureusement jamais papier moi je
regrette marcel maréchal mais ne partez
pas vous allez comprendre pourquoi
valérie jouer avec marcel maréchal bien
sûr pour tracer votre ligne il est un
animal marcel maréchal pour lequel il ne
reste que trois chasseurs
professionnelle en france quelle est
cette alim a récité mois plein d'animaux
on va bien tomber sur le bon top chrono
le grill non lours non lapin de garenne
non nous eh ben non je pense qu'il y
aura que l'on la bête de théâtre non est
doté le blaireau donc le serpent lequel
à sonnette
non alors la vie c'est oui
au fond ne soufflait pas mais on siffle
et enfin une ligne félicitations avoue
valérie grâce à la réponse de marcel
maréchal sein de supplémentaire pour
vous les compte 130 à 2 pour 10 pts qui
a deux james ami photographe il va
falloir vous ressaisir
notre deuxième rendez vous tout de suite
si vous êtes d'accord avec le dernier
des neuf coucou et avant de jouer au
dernier 2,9 je me dirige justement vers
marseille matches comme ça on quitte
marseille
qu'est ce qui se passe on ne s'y plaît
plus à marseille la criée vous aussi oui
mais moi je rentre tous les week-ends
mais c'est ça moi aussi
non non on est ici affectivement à paris
avec deux spectacles les 3 mousquetaires
à créteil le jour jusqu'au 27 février et
puis au rond-point des champs-elysées
chez chez jean louis barrault spectacle
est coproduit par la criée par jean
louis barrault et madeleine renaud avec
marie christine barrault et moi aussi je
joue là dedans je joue le rôle-titre
dylan une pièce de l'auteur américain
cindy michael ce alors parlons des trois
mousquetaires crée d'ailleurs au théâtre
de la criée à marseille c'est ça voilà
alors c'est important de décentraliser
la création pour ensuite revenir à paris
c'est une à paris c'est une ville de
tournai comme une autre très bien je
sens et autres vont entendre dire le les
cascades de ces les combats assez
justement on en parle avec jean marc
thibault la cc dans un prestigieux
cascadeur enfin non c'est un comédien
aussi mais qui qui sait très bien réglé
ça que c'est raoul biret qui a fait un
travail magnifique on a travaillé
pendant cinq mois avec avec des
cascadeurs et des comédiens françois
dunoyer qui fait d'artagnan et je crois
que c'est assez s'éteint c'est un des
gros atouts du spectacle où je n'aurais
pas pu faire ce spectacle sans s'enroule
vraiment un grand spécialiste paris
après marseille n'est qu'une étape pour
ces trois mousquetaires bas après nous
allons retourner l'enfance et puis après
nous partons en amérique du sud mais
j'ai les questions qu'on a joué aussi ça
en chine puisque ce sera le premier
contact avec la chine
oui avec l'amérique du sud aussi
j'ai fait beaucoup de tournées enfin pas
avec ce spectacle mais avec d'autres
spectacles en en europe et enfin
dans toute l'europe et dans tous les
pays socialistes et en amérique aussi du
nord mais jamais en amérique du sud et
jamais évidemment en chine
marcel maréchal merci d'en tenir compte
car vous les trois mousquetaires à
créteil nous sommes bien d'accord ça
emerson et celle de comédien avec marie
christine barrault dans une mise en
scène de jean pierre grand ou alors au
point des champs elysées je suis pas
très doué pour le jeu là je suis désolé
pour james
je suis très intimidé si j'avais pas mes
cartons pour james maintenant c'est un
vrai ou faux donc il n'y a pas cinquante
solutions vous allez voir avant sa
première question 1
j'enlève le trombone voilà un eudémis
est une figure en patinage artistique
vrai ou faux marcel à ce faux c'est faux
entièrement d'accord et oui c'est un
papillon très bonne réponse de marcel
maréchal
alice dona on peut lire à lys bon j'ai
filé dans l'académie alice un aigle
peugue l'attirent glh et ir un aigle
peugue l'attirent vrai ou faux platine
et ben faleh allons-y oui oui mal écrit
il faut valérie un aigle peugue latioui
but inscrit je regrette valérie vous ne
marquez pas vous dis à 2 alice reste
avec nous monsieur castelli monsieur
castelli perdu lui est une parabole
mathématiques l'hyper du lait oui est
une parabole mathématiques avec pour une
vraie vitrine il faut qu'on soit
d'accord
eh bien c'est faux bravo philippe
castets c'est le culte de la sainte
vierge chez les catholiques
c'était aussi maintenant oui si malade
et je me relève parce que je suis un peu
écroulé en plus vous êtes vraiment des
quoi site est aujourd'hui
alors c'est le moment que j'ai là la
langue autriche oui et un singe de sa
tombe encore sur vous l'amérique du sud
ah ah et bah c'est complètement faux
faux d'accord et bien c'est complètement
vrai au revoir sim
merci beaucoup à la race et arrêtent
didier houi une personne atrabilaire est
une personne ayant subi l'ablation de la
vésicule biliaire
non c'est faux c'est une personne qui a
qui est de mauvaise humeur
qu'en pensez vous parce que si bien pour
lui que gérer ou excellent en visitant
ces précisions apportées par notre ami
relève didier fait c'est en effet une
personne d'humeur chagrine c'est bien
mais n'est le misanthrope c'est le
l'atrabilaire amoureux je crois oui tout
à fait l'ex-ministre ans richard strauss
et un compositeur de nationalité
allemande vrai ou faux maintenant je
comprend d'anciens autrichien alors vrai
ou faux
or quoi vite oui non allez faut pour dit
faux faux faux et yoann était autrichien
le premier le deuxième et richard et
c'est bien là
au revoir monsieur menez ou catherine
lara
catherine la moldavie est une république
de l'union soviétique vrai ou faux la
moldavie vrai ou faux faux faux
j'irai faut aussi et bien c'est parfait
et d'autant que c'est vrai je regrette
merci enfin catherine à tout à l'heure
jean marc thibault en 1804 napoléon et
mythes un projet de campagne en
australie vrai ou faux vrai vrai ouais
ouais bonne réponse en effet de jean
marc thibault vrai il reste en notre
compagnie c'est à micheline missionné
maintenant de jouer pishin le bénin est
une province du gabon le bénin est une
province du cap un faux ou dit faux
james gilles faut aussi c'est faux bien
sûr c'est l'ex dahomey c'est un pays le
bénin
merci voyons voir marcel maréchal vous
êtes toujours là le premier rallye paris
dakar s'est déroulée en 1979 vrai ou
faux marcel vraie vraie nuit vrai c'est
vrai en effet bonne réponse de marcel
maréchal spécialiste en paris dakar et
face à marseille c'est énorme et ça
passe par marseille
l'italie a remporté la coupe du monde de
foot 1982 sur un score de 2 à 1 contre
l'allemagne
vrai ou faux oui mais alors 2 1 vrai ou
faux
oui allez je dirais vrai vrai j ai le
troisième but vous l'avez ou blanc
oh c'était 3 avec la demi-finale -
mercialys à l'école philippe castelli un
barda qui va sans doute répondre avant
même que je ne formulent la question les
indes orientales sont les anciennes
colonies néerlandaises formant
aujourd'hui l'indonésie oui c'est vrai
et bien c'est vrai merci beaucoup
willy kerthe elie avec lui présente
mandarin est un mot d'origine portugaise
mandarin oui je veux dire je m'en fous
totalement vrai ou faux je crois que
c'est vrai bref je revends c'est en
effet très très bonne réplique en est
didier jean lartigau s'est mêlé s em
peut elle le sait mêler avec 3 accent
est le dieu grec du vin et de l'ivresse
bacchus étant celui des romains vrai ou
faux
wilko est belle oui j'aimerais vous
dites vrai mais c'est faux bien sûr
merci beaucoup
c'était dionysos ah oui en argent là on
ira boire un verre tout à l'heure michel
luccioni le béryl bem y
elle est une variété d'émeraude oui j'en
ai même le berry dette une variété
d'émeraude vous dites vrai ah oui j'ai
dit frais si on en a vu j'ai confiance
je livre le problème c'est que celle
inverse l'émeraude qui est une variété
de béryl tomber dans les brodeurs
fiona aller chez nous ça ne va pas oui
mantis païenne est un insecte au même
titre que la mante religieuse
oui ouais vous dites frais ouais c'est
en effet vraiment de réponse de marcel
maréchal
on va pas les départager les 20 mille
cas ce qu'a dit louis xiv une sépulture
nocturne car on craignait des émeutes
populaires hostiles des faits vrais
ouais c'est vrai je dirais c'est en
effet vrai félicitations aux philippe
castelli et les plus profondes questions
de tous même les pauses et ensuite d'en
servir à des questionnaires dit de
blocage pour vous départager
c'est acquis joey starr mais je crois
oui elle est à moi je suis toujours là
morphée et la déesse grecque des songes
morphée oui oui je crois aux jouets fut
d'accord très bien morphée
c'est le dieu et non pas la déesse de
soja rebelles séparatistes et une
divinité apporte ce sont les fous c'est
le dieu des c'est un monsieur morphée je
regretterai didier et maintenant il nous
faut départager
marcel maréchal et philippe castelli
marcel maréchal la plus haute montagne
de grande bretagne est situé en écosse
c'est faux c'est faux j'ai info vous dit
faux c'était vrai merci beaucoup
d'enseignants et challes et nous allons
a clamé le dernier des neuf en la
personne de philippe castelli
bon ça va ça va merci faire des castings
vous jouez pour valérie un sens à deux
supplémentaires pour valérie georges -
noé le vrai nom de georges courteline
c'est un cadeau vrai ou faux
c'est vrai c'est vrai vrai c'est en
effet vrai félicitations à notre héros
de ce deuxième jeu le dernier castelli
qui permit bon ben vous pouvez atterrir
maintenant occupés comme et à valérie de
s'enrichir de 100 à 2 supplémentaires
les scores 282 pour valérie brigitte
voulez vous remettre les billets 70 à
deux pour james et tout de suite le
premier rendez-vous en chansons avec
notre invité de la semaine voici alice
dona laisser passer la chanson alice
dona